[Music]
coti de pablo may be known for ncis but
did you know she co-hosted a television
series at 15. keep watching to find out
how dipablo transformed into the artist
people know and love today
born maria jose de pablo fernandez in
santiago chile de pablo moved with her
family to miami florida after her mother
was hired as a talk show host at the
spanish language television network
telemundo while acclimating to her new
surroundings other kids had trouble
pronouncing maria jose so de pablo told
them to call her koti a traditional
nickname for her given name as a child
de pablo developed a love of music and
entertainment but her drive for the arts
didn't really start until she attended
an elective drama class in middle school
speaking with carnegie mellon today in a
2010 interview di pablo reminisced about
a pivotal moment during this class
saying i remember i was on stage in a
scene and something happened and i
called somebody
my teacher took me off stage gave me
detention i said to myself there's
something very wrong with this class i
knew i just needed to find the proper
class after middle school de pablo
attended new world school of the arts
pursuing her newfound passion at 15
years old dipablo worked as a co-host
for the latin american talk show control
from 1994 to 1995. she hosted episodes
alongside carlos ponce who was at the
time a rising star in latin american
telenovelas
after high school de pablo was driven to
continue her formal acting education she
told carnegie mellon today of how she
knew that carnegie mellon university
known for its fantastic music theater
program was the right place for her
recalling i always felt like they
understood me i was pretty complex i was
an immigrant and my family was very far
away i was both incredibly fragile and
incredibly strong and i think they could
see that and i will always be grateful
for that while at cmu de pablo
participated in many notable university
musicals which included and the world
goes round the fantastics the running
musical in history and the late great
stephen sondheim's 1973 musical a little
night music upon graduating in 2000 with
a bachelor of fine arts and musical
theater de pablo joined the ranks of
other famous actors who've made it
through carnegie mellon university this
list includes the likes of ted danson
holly hunter renee elise goldsberry and
ethan hawk
after college de pablo determined her
best move was to relocate to new york
city and start auditioning for roles so
she did exactly that in a 2007 interview
with the jewish journal de pablo spoke
about working as a waitress in manhattan
and brooklyn to pay the bills while
performing in william shakespeare's
measure for measure at the new york city
public theater her first screen
appearance came in a volkswagen
commercial which was succeeded by minor
work and single episodes of the
television series the street and the
education of max bickford as well as a
voice role in the 2002 racing video game
toca race driver yeah
maybe later on you could take me out for
you hey you cut this crap and get the
hell up there during this time de
pablo's passion for music was also
thriving and she snagged a supporting
role in the stage adaptation of the 1992
academy award-nominated feature film the
mambo kings which was based on the 1989
pulitzer prize-winning novel the mambo
kings play songs of love by oscar e
huelos while the musical's trial run in
san francisco was staged with the hope
that it would soon move to broadway poor
reviews canceled any further production
plans de pablo subsequently would star
in the only season of the 2004 law drama
the jury in which she played her first
major recurring role
while de pablo was working on the mambo
kings she submitted a videotape audition
for the role of special agent david for
ncis a series at the time known mainly
as a growing spin-off of the popular
television series jag after sending in
her tape de pablo was called into los
angeles for a screen test with michael
weatherly one of her future ncis
co-stars what are you saying
she's saying you're a car killer
what a car killer everybody needs a
hobby in an interview with tv fanatic in
2009 de pablo spoke about her experience
when weatherly decided to start
improvising i just thought oh my god
this guy is sabotaging my audition i
will not allow this actor to do this to
me so what people saw in the audition
room really was a person fighting the
other person back and refusing to give
even an inch it was just all the things
that i think later on translated to the
relationship that ziva and tony had and
still have despite throwing to pablo off
her game weatherly's move and the
pablo's response seemed to work as the
actress was offered the part de pablo's
character of mossad agent ziva david
filled the spot left by sasha
alexander's special agent kate todd
who's brutally killed in the season 2
finale of ncis originally designed to be
european the writers and producers of
ncis changed david's backstory to be
israeli de pablo put a lot of effort
throughout her time on ncis into making
her character feel as authentic as
possible despite the fact that the
actress isn't jewish herself she learned
how to speak hebrew realistically very
early on and de pablo went even further
studying the history of jewish
civilization and culture her devotion to
her performance has kept david a fan
favorite character and has netted to
pablo numerous award nominations and an
alma award in 2011 for outstanding
actress in a drama television series
after eight seasons on ncis de pablo
decided to leave the show cbs claimed to
have offered de pablo a considerable
contract to entice her to stay but she
explained in a 2016 q a which was quoted
in a 2019 article by vanity fair
i worked eight years crafting this
character and loving her and so when i
felt or i perceived that the character
was not being treated with the respect
that she deserved no money in the world
would make me stay luckily for fans de
pablo wasn't done with david just yet
returning in season 17 for a
five-episode arc helping out mark
harmon's character agent gibbs and
finishing up her character's storyline
and when they called you and said hey
you want to come back what did you say i
said yes write a really nice storyline
and why not outside of ncis de pablo
gained a claim and accolades for her
performance in the feature film the 33
and though she was possibly executive
producing a television series with
weatherly it seems to have stalled her
last on-screen credits were in the 2018
short film the crossing and the 2019
indie feature film seneca with nothing
currently set for the near future check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about ncis
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]